let's talk about this guy in iraq
uh iraq who is who is teaching swimming
lessons
because this is another cool story i
don't know anything about this guy well
foreign service yeah dude jay taylor
um this is another story actually this
uh section of the book came he was also
another pen pal of mine
but he was a pen pal like a many like a
long time ago
he had read something that i'd written
for the new york times about um
swimming as the last refuge from
connectivity and he said you know
i have a story for you about how it
brought people together
and it was about community about
connection and um
he was this foreign service guy who got
sent to a rock
for a posting for a couple of years i
think it was 2008 to 2010
and it was a time when um
baghdad was seeing a lot of a lot of
active like
shelling activity and so it was a pretty
hairy time to be there and he was in the
green zone which at the time was part
was
in situated in saddam hussein's
republican palace now i don't know if
you know this but
saddam hussein and his sons were very
fond of swimming
and so at all of their palaces and homes
around
iraq they had these crazy
pools like just again like luxury
upon luxury in the desert is like having
a pool
that you keep filled and um
this pool had multi-level diving boards
in fact you can see
um there are some i don't know if
they're still up but there are some
youtube videos of
uh service soldiers yeah soldiers like
jumping off of the diving boards um
which doesn't actually it doesn't see
watching them doesn't speak well of us i
don't know there's just something wrong
we just we descend upon the palace and
take it over yeah
like a playground it's that kind of like
imperialist
um view that has so gotten us into
trouble but anyway
so um but in this time of war
of course there is a community that
forms around this pool because
of course everyone is drawn to this
at that pool yeah and suddenly they're
like wait we're allowed to use this pool
it is like
got fountains and tiles and diving
boards and it just is
glorious and again it's peace it's
finding quiet
and he said that when he um
would get in this pool he would just
then that's when he stopped hearing like
the firing
range you know you'd be muffled and
otherwise it's like this incessant
noise of like military exercises
and um you know the
the people who were there
were from all over the world you know
they're diplomats
soldiers u.n peacekeepers translators
local iraqis who were
you know there providing support and
he saw that
that pool was again like everyone all
the animals flocked to the watering hole
right
but this in this case it was like a
psychological
space like a coping mechanism coping
mechanism and
um he was swimming
he he taught swimming lessons for a long
time he was a
lifeguard you know had grown up in uh
the baltimore suburbs i think
dc and he
he has you know great form and he
uh started to teach let people come up
and say hey you got any
tips for me and he would see his
colleagues flailing around in the pool
and he would offer some tips and he's a
very
like when you read the book you
understand that he's just like a very
kind he's a teacher he's like
he's his his joy and his role in life is
to be a teacher
you know he's a very and to do it and
and
and you've you've encountered many
coaches over your life
as i buy and the best coach
is one who kind of instills a little bit
of fear
but all but but that but that you want
you it's authority you seek that
approval
you seek that approval i wouldn't say
that he's a person oh i don't know what
what he is like as a parent but um he's
a very gentle
guy at this point in his life but you
see that he has this quiet authority
that you
want to you know that he knows things
and you want him to share them with him
and so he was able to kind of i mean i
think of him as a pied piper of all of
these swimmers
in in the green zone because he kind of
was
he ended up building this you know
baghdad swim club of like a roster of
250 some odd people who rotated over
two years uh and would be teaching
swimming less i mean
they kept having to add classes because
they kept coming together it's like a
feel-good movie
yeah it's totally a feel-good movie jay
taylor folks you can contact me
for the rights with him
i didn't realize what really struck me
aside from that story is
this discussion around um
you know how beautiful the sunsets are
and like how people would swim
like sort of at dusk or at dawn like not
not at high noon it was too hot
but when the sand would kick up that's
when you would get the really epic
sunsets but that was also the danger
signal because that's when the incoming
mortars
occur right because that sand would
obscure
um the ability to find the people who'd
been hit
right right you it was cover
for um it was a good mortaring
opportunity
and it's just like to exist in that
reality like you're in this you have
this pool with fountains but right
outside of it
like people are getting shelled yeah um
and you know he jay almost got hit by a
mortar
um in his trailer like on the third day
he was in baghdad you know he
he really almost didn't live to um
[Music]
have this club you know teach these
people to swim and it is
it sort of underlines this
um just how again porousness between
states and one that's one of the big
themes of the book is like
we're i think with swimming
what's so intriguing to me about it is
that it is a sport it is a practice it
is
something we do for exercise but it is
it is
it is the difference between life and
death and water
that is the reality i mean that is crazy
and
we don't we don't dance very often
it's that close these days to death i
mean
last year this past year has been
an exceptional year to that but in our
modern day we don't experience that
acute acuteness
most of us don't anyway most of us are
lucky not to
and so i think sports of course
competition is a way to experience this
acuteness of being right this
um the adrenaline rush
the um the
urgency of feeling just really alive
and and oftentimes that
you know that feeling is something that
we
we kind of can only really approximate
um
with something that's a very heightened
experience
[Music]
you